Trump does very very well because of the
way the political establishment treats
the people who are exactly like the
residents of East Palestine Ohio The
Forgotten people the people in flyover
country the people who are deplorable
and irredeemable bitter clinging rube
toothless Gerard hillbilly hick idiots
that's what the people on the coast say
about pretty much everybody
from I don't know 200 miles into the
West Coast 200 miles into the East Coast
everybody in the middle terrible useless
deplorables and Trump does very well
with them his numbers are reflecting
that speaking of feedback Trump uh just
won the CPAC straw poll
and you want to buy a country mile 62
percent of the respondents at the straw
poll
voted for Trump
Rhonda Santos did not show up to CPAC he
still came in second though he got 20
third place went to a Michigan
billionaire in Perry Johnson
so does that matter well the CPAC straw
poll
it's got actually a pretty decent record
in predicting the nominee not perfect
it's a little bit of a mixed bag
some straw polls though don't matter at
all the CPAC one does a little bit in
2020 obviously they picked Trump in 2016
the CPAC straw poll picked Cruz
and Cruz was the number two guy he
almost got the nomination but it went to
Trump in 2012 the CPAC straw poll picked
Romney 2008 also picked Romney so they
got that one wrong in 2000 they picked
Bush they got that one right Dole in 96
they got that one right Buchanan in 92
they got that one wrong Reagan in 1980
they got that one obviously right so
it's a mixed bag but Trump winning it I
think is a pretty decent sign especially
for the kinds of candidates you know
CPAC was founded basically for Ronald
Reagan
and Reagan showed up he tried to show up
every single year of his presidency I
think once he was not able to make it
for an emergency but he said he had to
show up to see back because he wanted to
dance with the gal that brung him and he
felt that CPAC was was representing that
conservative Grassroots movement
obviously it's changed a lot over the
years but
I think the conclusion has to be no
matter how well DeSantis is doing he's
governing very well he's campaigning
very well even though he hasn't
officially declared he's running yet but
I think in this race Trump Remains the
favorite he remains the guy to be
not just CPAC showing this there was a
Yahoo yougov poll that was released it
was last week showing that 47 percent of
Republicans would vote for Trump in a
head-to-head primary against DeSantis
that means that DeSantis is eight points
behind Trump right now at 39 13
undecided so Trump could or DeSantis
rather could still take it but even
according to that poll
Trump wins
and it's important that that's a
head-to-head poll because again early
polls don't matter that much and it
really depends on the state and the
caucus or the primary but nevertheless
the conventional wisdom had been if
Trump runs he can clear the field then
he gets the nomination if Trump ran he
did not clear the field
if it's Trump versus DeSantis DeSantis
wins but if he really doesn't clear the
field and a lot of other candidates get
in as we're seeing now Nikki Haley's
gotten into that Rama Swami's getting in
there are a lot of other people who are
predicted to get him then in a split
field Trump is going to be able to hold
his plurality let's say he doesn't get
50 plus but he holds that plurality just
like he did in 2016 he wins the
nomination
so the fact that right now Trump is
head-to-head beating DeSantis
very good sign for Trump and and also
what it means is that right now people
are living in Echo Chambers
so
the people who everyone's talking to in
the primary campaigns tend to be the
people of like mind like social status
like uh personal interest and so you're
seeing especially among the pundits a
gravitation toward Ron DeSantis and a
lot of other people too I'm plenty of
people really really like Ron DeSantis
but I'm not sure that's totally
reflective of every part of the GOP base
certainly this early when Ron DeSantis
doesn't have anywhere near the name
recognition that Trump does because the
the primary has not really taken off yet
the member block begins now head on over
it's music Monday baby and I am going to
put all of my
uh cultural Maven focus and prudence and
insight
towards our new song go to dailywire.com
use code Knowles kwles a checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you there
[Music]